hey guys so you guys probably don't know  this from watching my channel because I  never put anything about it but I'm a  huge fan of music and I play music and I  used to have a piano channel and I want  to bring it back I just want to make it  a part of the channel because this  channel is a more personal expression of  me so just know that we're gonna start  music Mondays music Mondays starting now  we're starting with Biddy in the jets  which I'm probably totally incompetent  to play because it's Elton John but I  did it anyway so here's to a rough start  thanks for watching  [Music]  whether kill the body cap tonight so  stick around  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh video jam  [Music]